every time you create a new piece of
content that can then also serve as
additional at the end of other videos of
mashup content that you now are doubling
tripling quadrupling 10x in the length
of each video and don't feel guilty
about reusing what people like really
appreciate putting that back out there
it's a thing yeah it's one of the
biggest fighting points with Eddie was
like but people have already seen it and
they're not going to like that it's
there again it's like just try it dude
yeah he was right that's right I think
the coolest thing about something like
this is like there's just infinite
opportunity it's like wherever your
creativity can take you if you're taking
videos on the cruise of course yeah
you're there you're in person you edit
that whatever in between cruises but
like think about the content you can
create like five of the best things in
Mexico 10 reasons this Cruise wins you
know and like build an audience face to
face with someone who's not only like
showing you through awesome visuals and
all this stuff that you went through and
it was a blast but like delving into it
and giving your opinion and becoming an
authority on whatever those are and
great things will happen for you like
that's an achievable goal this year
I went on a cruise met a girl named
Chelsea and now we've been on four
cruises and we got four more booked and
we've been filming all of it and they're
taking off I got one with 40 000 views
now
um another couple with 10 12 000 views
so the travel stuff is just natural for
me just being able to
kind of show people the places and and
blow them away with it and then
all the years of playing with video and
cameras and all that stuff and I've been
picking up the photography again
shooting the locations and I've actually
gotten some uh
uh travel agents that are looking for
pictures so when I do travel I can kind
of use that as a secondary income still
trying to figure out that whole world of
what to do in between cruises trying to
keep the content going and stuff like
that and I'm learning but it's still a
struggle to try to figure out that
content
because they never do as well like what
are you capturing when you're you're on
the cruise I know you're taking pictures
but are you taking like uh is it like
Vlog type stuff or long form yeah it's
more of a vlogging Style
um but I'm doing room tours like the
last two cruises I've done room tours
I've done the cruise tour or the boat
tour of all the hot spots
and then I normally put out a video of
just kind of all the outtakes and fun
and craziness of it because that's kind
of what it's for so uh you know you
really want to have fun on it so I try
to show that part of it I've even been
trying to get people when I meet them on
the ship because the first one I went on
was a solo trip so I was really stuck
meeting people forced to it's kind of
how I met my girlfriend and uh so doing
that and then getting people to do you
want to be in the video and if they do I
let them kind of come along with me and
talk about the spots it just involves
them and I find that it helps they'll
share the hell out of it later
I mean it's kind of free I can get 30 40
subscribers right then and there just
one person so you know that kind of
stuff I'm trying to do and I've been
following a lot of the other ones that
have done it and I got lucky on one of
the cruises that I met a guy that has
200 000 subscribers and he's been doing
cruising for five years
so he's been I've been talking to him on
and off
and he does most of his content from his
house he'll film the whole boat but then
he'll do voice over
where mine is kind of in the moment so
it's just kind of trying to fill myself
out that's that's exactly where I was
going to go I mean I think the coolest
thing about something like this is like
there's just infinite opportunity it's
like wherever you your creativity can
take you so if you're like the way my
brain goes with what you're saying is
like if you're taking uh videos on the
cruise
um of course yeah you do your you know
you're there you're in person you edit
that whatever in between cruises but
like think about the content you could
create like five of the best things in
Mexico 10 reasons this Cruise wins you
know and like build an audience face to
face with someone who's not only like
showing you through awesome visuals and
all this stuff that you went through and
it was a blast but like delving into it
and giving your opinion and becoming an
authority on on whatever those are like
that's I feel like the a little hanging
fruit yeah because we're really trying
to hit every Cruise Line like every
Private Island because it seems like
those videos do extremely well
um people want to know about the
individual private islands of all the
different companies so we're really
trying to spread out amongst five or six
different companies and hit every one of
those that way I can come back on the
back end of that and say you know what
do I pick from these five different
private islands and then I have true
life experience so I'm not just talking
off of videos I've seen so trying to
Parlay that uh my other friend has one
really crazy idea that we'd like to pull
off is try to get like four YouTubers to
go and see what we can create on a
cruise
and just stick us all in one room
for like five days and see what happens
and make everybody make a video out of
it and just put that out trying to
figure out some way to do a cool collab
because I just missed the um vloggers
cruise I didn't know about it until a
week before it happened and it went out
in New Orleans and I was like huh I
could have gone but uh they're doing the
vloggers cruise but really no really
good they had almost 40 uh content
creators on that cruise and no real
content came out of it do you want to do
like are you committed to cruises like
that's the thing that you love the most
more than just travel or or seeing hot
spots no me I don't care I love it all
like that's my that's always my problem
I love I don't care what kind of travel
it is it's just my girlfriend's really
into cruising and it's comfortable and
it's a lot easier to plan than trying to
do your own because it's all preset for
you okay so so
a couple things one uh you make a list
of all the people who are doing Cruise
content all those 40 people that went on
the thing go get their names
okay did you message them not yet
message them let them know what you're
doing let them know you're in the space
you're excited about it where are you
going in your next cruise maybe you
could do some kind of collaboration that
guy who had the 300K Subs
when's his next Cruise yeah he's going
uh he's doing one in June we're trying
to hook up with him on June yeah we're
already working on that great but but
like if you have one guy then you're
you're at the whim of the one guy in his
schedule if you got 30 38 yeah then it's
like then there's somebody leaving every
week going somewhere right that maybe
you should hop in and join right so and
and the more you stay in any industry
which is you know kind of been one of
your challenges it's like let's stay
consistent on something right but like
if this is something that you want to do
for a couple years then you're gonna
start building up connections
in there that will help people right and
and like help you continue to build as
well
um the second thing is you if you're
going to stay committed to this uh you
want to be looking at crew sponsorships
so that you're not out of pocket to pay
for everything
and you've already been in touch with
MSC um MSC has an affiliate program or
not an affiliate program what do they
call YouTubers influencer influencer
program great
so contacted them um though when I went
on my last trip I booked it five days
before they they like that's just not
enough time for us to do anything for
you contact us when the next one goes
out so we booked the next one for June
1st and uh we've already I've already
contacted them it's it's the kind of
thing like you find all the major cruise
lines and even the smaller ones whatever
and and you find contacts and every
month you're in touch
because you never know when the right
time is gonna hit and like they have
something coming up and then you can go
and now if you're on the influencer
program they'll often put you in a
better room because they want you to
show off like the fancy stuff which will
then help you get more views and you're
not paying out of pocket for
you know booking the actual Cruise yeah
right so whether that's you doing it or
your girlfriend's gonna do it if she
loves the cruises like build the
connections message every Cruise Line
and the key contacts there every month
and then there's something new to show
because your stuff looks good right I
mean you're not just like here's a shaky
cell phone right your stuff looks fire
um so yeah those two things like build
the network with with your the other
Cruise traveler so it's fun and like
you're the guy who can organize things
and you're traveling and you you get to
collab and then build the connection
with the cruise ships that you could be
leaving you could be spending zero days
at home if you wanted to
that's going to be the goal for 2023.
okay so maybe like by the end of 23 or
mid right like yeah with the cruise
lines but yeah the crew's leaving every
day
I mean we're looking at 30 days and
stuff like that so you could definitely
build that up but you have to and I'm
also I think the bonus is is I've
already made contact with five different
travel agents
um three of them actually contacted me
and that's what gave me the idea to
contact two more because it could just
be a side gig hey we want pictures of
all these islands and we'll pay XML for
pictures and that's easy to do on the
side and it's just another form of
income so it's taking all of these small
things and just pushing like crazy on
them so it's not just this one guy it's
a hundred travel vloggers it's not just
five travel agents it's 500 travel
agents it's not just one Cruise Line
it's 25 Cruise Lines right and you just
throw massive action against all those
things
and great things will happen for you
like that's that's an achievable goal
this year if you want I think by the end
of this year it's easily achievable so
I'm actually excited because I actually
trust this one you know it's like fun
good I love it dude believe it we're
cheering you on dude all right
now every Sunday everyone come my good
day okay and I great I create the
Whiteboard animations
with everyone uh what's over then I post
on the YouTube at the YouTube shops so
any advice for me as uh this morning
we're talking about we need to create a
long form uh video so any advice for me
to create a more long-term video instead
of just creating the shot
okay so he makes short like white form
white whiteboard animation kind of
videos oh those are awesome yeah and
well this is like Eddie went from making
three minute short like it's not as
short as yours but three minutes or
three hours so what's the process to go
from short to Long
yeah so I mean it all comes to story
like I think what helps is it's funny
you're still gonna hit the same point
and that's the question right going from
short to Long here yep yeah okay so
you're still gonna hit like if you were
to get a Microsoft Word document or
whatever and bull it out what you want
to say it probably wouldn't be very
different it would just be there's more
information between the points right so
you can give more examples so if you're
doing a whiteboard uh video and it's uh
let's say a minute you have three things
and you say them quick you have to if
you want to make that 10 minutes you're
taking those three things you're giving
examples you're maybe uh adding uh
details or stories that support that so
like the thing that is is sort of
comforting is that you don't need to
reinvent the wheel here there's nothing
like brand new you're doing you're just
adding more context so that you can
elongate what you're saying it's like a
book for example like books are great
because there's a ton of detail on them
but they don't need to be books you
could put the main points of a book uh
non-fiction on on one page you know so
you're taking uh one page and you're
making it uh you know a bestseller I'll
get it that way
the other thing Eddie did was he he did
mashups where he would he's not writing
if he does a three hour video that's not
three hours of new content true that's
his old stuff mixed together so there
might be like one new thing at the front
and then he'll throw
a couple hours of old stuff on
afterwards which is a bunch of these
three minute videos uh I may be 10 a
little bit longer because he's been
doing it for so long so every time you
create a new piece of content that can
then also serve as
additional at the end of other videos
those mashup content that you now are
doubling tripling quadrupling 10x in the
length of each video and don't feel
guilty about reusing the people like
really appreciate putting that back out
there it's a thing you know it's one of
the biggest fighting points with Eddie
was like but people have already seen it
and they're not gonna like that it's
there again it's like just try it dude
yeah he was right that's right I had 24
videos yeah already yeah video uh voice
over so I I might try together yeah and
you can do it just me but you can also
do either if you're doing other people
you can also mix them up if you have me
and garyvee and Grant Cardone and Mel
Robbins or whoever and you're mixing
them all together that could also be its
own mix too
so like don't think about the work
you've already done
yes
it's only me okay well thank you but you
got 24 of me so then now you can make a
mashup of the 24. right and and as you
keep adding to your library then you can
continue to extend the videos too
all right thank you very much I would
like to know how do you organize like
every time that you present a story how
do you organize it in your mind like to
make it impactful like do you have a
structure that is your go-to so you can
put the ideas fast
um you know present them in a in an
effective way yeah that's a really good
question I mean so the the way that I've
found it most effective is you know I'll
have a list of topics that I'll keep in
my notes section and then the format and
it varies depending on the story you
want to tell but like if I really
simplified it it would be one is opening
with a quote or an introduction like
explaining all right guys here's what
we're diving into like here's the topic
or the question let's explore
and then I go into what's called earning
the tell uh like
my experience with it so that I'm never
saying like hey you guys need to do this
or if you don't do this no it's hey guys
yesterday I did this and this was
awesome and I'm gonna do it again and
you know maybe you can use it right and
so that's that's the middle it's like
the story and then the end is saying the
so what and that's giving the the quote
unquote advice or saying like here's
what I think is beneficial in talking
about it more uh tangibly as far as like
actionable Steps let's say that I ask
you like by chance I ask you please tell
me story about how you ended up being an
influencer what would be like your
structure
yeah so if I was going to talk to a
group about being an influencer it would
be uh an introductory like quote about
like when I think about being an
influencer I think about being able to
um take your authenticity and give it to
the world I think of an exciting Journey
so a quote like um one of my favorites I
just mentioned it like not all who
wander are lost right and then meaning
it's okay to not know and then I would
go into the story of like so me with my
acoustic guitar all I knew is that I
didn't want to be in the insurance world
that's all I knew but I went out and
um tried some things failed some things
learned what I didn't want uh understood
what I did and practice and practice and
practiced and found something found that
intersection of what I love and what
adds value to the world so that's my
story and then I'd end with you know the
so what so if you want to be an
influencer and you feel like you know
you can't leave what you have because
things are so I would say like here are
some steps you can take uh to maybe uh
little by little acclimate yourself or
some things you can do that allow you to
you know move into it so it's it's like
the tangible steps after the story
how to manage work-life balance while
serving others but still avoiding
burnout so I talk about burnout super
quick in here there's not a lot on it
it's like one page on it maybe two I
think
burnout mostly happens when you don't
love what you're doing
when I if you know for example like
accounting I would burn out so fast if I
had to be an accountant I just it's just
not what I love doing
um or legal work or paperwork or
contracts and my mom's a lawyer and she
loves it right like that's her service
it's like I'm gonna say people from
making tons of mistakes in their
business that's her service but for me
every time I get a contract that I look
at like oh how many pages is it okay
four okay it's not that bad
so I would get burned out super fast if
I was a lawyer
but I could do this
for a much much much longer time right
I've been going I started this morning
I'm you know two o'clock I haven't had a
break I'm gonna go all through tonight
and and it's not gonna it's not gonna
feel like work like I'm I'm doing a
stream tonight with Zan and Drew from
you know six to eight ish Zan's all
excited he's like you guys should show
up uh that I'm not looking at that like
oh really
I don't know Zan you know uh right I'm
I'm pumped I'm pumped to do it it
doesn't I don't see it as work and so I
think a lot of burnout happens because
you don't actually love the work that
you're doing
when I I was telling the story on the
podcast just before this so I broke my
neck when I was on tour right and
everybody wanted me to come home and I
tell the story and build the serve
uh said how about we just try because
I would much rather be here with
entrepreneurs than at home what I'm
gonna do at home just lie in the bed and
feel sorry for myself like I'd much
rather be with entrepreneurs because for
me that's service that's love and love
is healing
so I'd much rather be a part of the love
energy that we get from like hey just
can you just give me four hours where I
don't have to feel my pain because I can
just be here helping entrepreneurs
uh and so
there were some limits and there were
some controls like my first speech uh my
first event was in Kansas City and we I
only went for an hour and a half instead
of the usual three to four hours because
my wife pulled me off and said that's um
you're done like I'm she was the boss
the agreement was she would pull me
aside when I'm when I'm hitting my limit
uh because otherwise I would go too far
um and if she wasn't in charge then she
wouldn't let me go
and I could not drive there by myself
because my neck was broken
um
so that was the only time where she ever
had to pull me off stage for the rest of
the entire tour and and I didn't feel
burnt out I felt like this was actually
part of my healing
um so there is definitely time for
self-care and there was definitely time
for going too far but I would really
look at
the tasks that are actually burning you
out it's probably because you're
spending too much time especially with
people that are just draining your
energy as opposed to lifting you up
so think about the people that you're
around you know I see John in the room
John's part of Genius Network I am too
and whenever we're in in the genius
network uh those are long events like
those are two full days once a month
you're booking off your whole Thursday
whole Friday but
but when you come back it's like oh it's
already five o'clock what happened
like so many great people so many caring
people so many people who want to serve
who want to give who want to who want to
help each other out and it doesn't feel
like you're spending a lot of time but
again if you put me in a two-day legal
conference oh my God I'm gonna be
distracted the whole time I'm going to
be doing Instagram I'm gonna be
something because I'm going to hate my
life right so a lot of times it's just
spending time with people who the people
who who suck your energy you want to
limit how much time you're spending with
them and it's not they may not be bad
people just doing work that you just
don't like doing versus
you know how good it's felt when you've
helped somebody you know when you help
somebody when you've given them wisdom
when you've told them your story and you
see the glimmer of hope in their eyes
say maybe I can do this too
you know that feels so good
and you could do that again right
afterwards and not feel drained and
you're not going to go home saying I'm
so burnt out like the nights that I
sleep the best somebody asked me how do
you what's your sleep schedule how do
you sleep the best and the usual advice
is like okay don't drink coffee after
two o'clock and have cool sheets and you
know uh have have the lights all the way
down and blackout curtains and all that
and that's all true I'm not negating any
of that but the thing for me is I say
best when I feel like I gave my best you
know like like today mattered like I
helped somebody today
that's when I I can just
what a delicious day ready to pass out
what if I feel like I didn't give enough
I played small I didn't help I wasted my
time today then I'm Restless no matter
how cool the beds is or how dark the the
light is and all that stuff right so I
think that when you can get more into
service mode I think burnout is still
real but it's it's a lot less I think
like imagine a world like how many
people are burnt out in the world right
I mean
how many how much of America is burnt
out right now Lots but imagine if
95 of America was getting burned out
because they were serving each other so
much right like that's that's a much
nicer world to live in right so I think
burnout is real but it's not usually the
cause of um
uh of serving too much it's usually
because we're doing a lot of work that
we don't like so again it is real your
balance and your self-care does
definitely matter but most of the
burnouts coming from things that you
just shouldn't be doing anymore
um I think for for balance you work life
balance that's uh it's a personal thing
and a shifting thing so I look at Dwayne
Johnson and he's always the example I go
to because he's kind of crazy in his
work in four hours a day like he's got
to work for work out four hours a day
right which sounds crazy to me that's
crazy right but I don't look like Dwayne
Johnson
right this is what you look like when
you don't work out four hours a day and
he's got to wake up five hours early to
go work out four hours a day to then get
to his set and to me that sounds crazy
but the him he's in the zone and that's
his like private place and meditation
like he he has to do it he's not the
same guy if he doesn't do his his
workout for four hours
um so that's his version of balance even
though we might judge it or at least I
judge it and say wow that is like not it
at all that's the opposite of balance so
it's a constant
struggle battle uh to look at your
calendar because all you got is your
time
does your the actions in your calendar
map to the Ambitions of you achieving
the life that you want
personal and business right so
um you know Saturday is my day with my
wife
and so
before covet we were doing I would
always book a new restaurant for us to
go to something new in the city for us
to go to and you couldn't reach me on a
Saturday if you follow me on Instagram I
I almost never post on a Saturday and if
I post in something it's me in in the
woods going on a hike or something but I
don't do I don't take questions I do my
10 questions with Evan every day except
Saturday
so you can ask me a question on set
because that's the time that I spent
dedicated to her
uh and whatever you might judge that and
say well that's stupid Evan if you're
trying to grow your business you got to
do XYZ or you might say well that's not
enough time you got to spend Friday
Saturday and Sunday like everybody's
gonna have an opinion on what you should
be doing
you're never gonna please everybody
people will always judge you for what
you're doing so at the end of the day it
just comes down to what do you want
what's balance for you
you know you you how much time you want
to spend with your your husband or wife
with your kids because news flash you
don't want to spend all day with your
husband or wife either
you don't want to spend all day long
with your husband or wife doing nothing
you don't want to spend all day long in
your business you don't want to spend
all day long at the gym so like how does
that balance fit
um and I would make sure you have time
for yourself whatever that looks like
like what is personal time for you
whether that's
um being part of something like Movie
Makers or genius Network whether that's
playing the guitar or playing some video
games or like what like your own
personal time because you need to have
your own time for your own growth so
whatever that looks like for you and
again varying amounts for some people
they need half an hour or an hour every
day and some people it's just something
on the weekend
but
I would I would look at my account it's
what I do I look at my calendar your
calendar is a reflection of your goals
and Ambitions right because success is
your habits it's what you're doing every
day that counts so you look at your
habits and if I do these things will
this lead to a happy life
financially spiritually emotionally
relationships like if I do these things
will it lead to a happier life and if
yes then great you do it and if not then
you change something
and most people wait to to have
something fall so far out of their life
that they make a major change
what I would love to see you do is make
more micro changes
so most people don't make a change until
they don't change their diet until they
have a heart attack you know they don't
they don't they don't quit that job and
look for a business until they just hate
their their boss so much that they have
to leave
instead of making these macro
adjustments it's better to make more
micro adjustments more frequently
so you change your schedule maybe every
week in a little tiny way if you need to
instead of sticking with the same
schedule and then five years later
totally hating your life and then having
to make some major change
um so constantly I'm looking at my
calendar and it's a reflection of what
means the most to me covet has changed a
lot of things obviously for me for
everybody
um
so look at your calendar for the next
week and say hey if I started doing
these tasks will I get closer to
achieving my goals or not
that's a good one that's a good that was
a good question hopefully a good answer
but thank you thank you Andrew uh so as
we go along guys I mean there's still
the ones in the Facebook group but if
you have questions while we're here pop
it in the chat I'll do my best to to
help answer uh Zan is saying you have to
enjoy the process BTS page 145 there you
go Dan I'm talking about there's one
about burnout there's a page on burnout
that specifically addresses that uh John
is asking seems as if you chose to work
with your natural gift and talent and
monetize it and make sure we structure
our business to fit our desired
lifestyle we last longer yeah 100
percent
100 I mean you got it John I I look at
um people who are looking forward to
retirement it's like well what what are
you retiring from right like we you want
to serve forever
and so my goal is to I want to be 120
years old and still helping
entrepreneurs in some way like I might
be in a wheelchair or I might be in a in
a home or something but as long as I can
think as long as I still got this like
everything else might fall apart but as
long as I still got my brain and I can
talk even if I can't talk I'll be
writing I'll be using my foot to paint
anything just to try to to help
um I don't I don't ever want to stop
doing it that's why the Who and the why
are constant forever and the how will
change a million different times but
um I've seen a lot of uh friends and and
parents of friends who as soon as they
stop serving as soon as they stop their
job like everything just falls apart
their health falls apart their relations
falls apart they don't have meaning
anymore and they're they're bored just
staying at home
um and so I never want to be that
um
it may not always be always on but this
service I think is it's just a human
need I think service is a human need
you always want to feel no matter how
old you are that you that today matters
to somebody that you can create
something that could change somebody's
life and that the time you spent today
was was well spent and that maybe that's
for the world or maybe that's just
spending time with your kids today and
have an impact on them or spending time
with your husband and wife today and
having an impact on them but you want to
feel like today was well spent and the
more days that you feel like you spent
the time well the happier you're going
to be and the more days you feel like
you wasted it
the more unhappy you're going to be and
I think that's why most so many people
are depressed is like they're spending
time feeling like it doesn't matter
like nobody cares if I show up today
nobody cares if I do hard work today
nobody cares that leads to depression
uh John says not planning on turning in
my parts until God calls me home right I
love it
I love it absolutely Raymond's saying I
have two offices that I float around to
I believe changing the environment is
huge yeah and listen that's plain to
play to your strengths like what works
for you is what you have to start to do
other people might say Raymond no that's
crazy dude like don't switch between two
offices you're unfocused you're all over
the place that doesn't work because
they're working off of their operating
system
and you know that this works for you so
you do it
like the most important part of
um I was talking to somebody earlier
today about a morning routine what's
your morning routine the most important
part of a morning routine is how it
makes you feel
it's not just about checking the boxes
this is different the difference between
normal people Achievers and high
achievers most people wake up and have
no routine at all they wake up like an
accident they fall into their day they
check their phone oh my God that and
then they're just a mess
right that's most people uh Achievers
have a routine chances are you guys have
a morning routine you know what you're
going to do every morning and you check
it off the problem is
there's no feeling in most of the time
of that morning routine
you're checking the Box because you know
that watching a video or reading that
book or listening to that podcast is the
thing that will get you fired up
but you're also doing it while you're
washing the dishes or brushing your
teeth or eating breakfast or something
else and so you don't get the feeling
you can check the box and see I did it I
did it
but you don't feel bold you don't feel
powerful you don't actually feel
inspired that's the difference you want
to move from being an achiever to a high
achiever your morning routine has to
make you feel bold powerful inspired and
ready to take on the day
and that might mean just keeping your
morning routine but doing it with more
intention
I had a woman show up to my event in um
New Mexico and she said I asked her
what's the most powerful part of the
morning routine it's like she said
prayer so prayer was the most powerful
part of my routine like every day you
pray every day I pray okay great how
many days do you pray and you get the
feeling of the closeness to God and
you're ready to go take on the day
and how many days do you feel like you
just kind of said the words
and she said about 50 50. like and
that's the problem right because you can
check the box to say I did it I prayed
all right next but if you're only
actually feeling it half the time the
other half the time it's it's not wasted
time but it's not actually serving you
that much
so look at your morning routine today
whatever the thing is prayer videos
workout whatever the most important
thing at your morning routine is are you
feeling bold powerful inspired and ready
to take on the day if yes you did a
great job if no go back and do it again
or add something else in that gets you
that feeling because we've all felt bold
and powerful and confident and inspired
we just don't live there naturally
so you have to inject that in like you
take a vitamin D supplement or a fish
oil supplement you need to have the the
belief supplement that you add to your
morning routine make it part of your
vitamins that you take every day the
belief supplement that I can do greater
things
right and that's that has to be a part
of your routine and that's different for
everybody maybe you watch The Rock
working out and that gets you jacked up
or maybe you watch The Rock working out
you think that guy's crazy
um I'm not here to judge what you have
to do but it's putting that in and
having the feeling so you can move from
being achiever to a high achiever
uh uh what else finding time for
self-care and reconnect so you have more
insight to pour into other people's cups
is it is it truth for family or for any
people we serve
um everybody like you show up and you
want to spread your message everywhere
um
I read a quote from Francis Assisi last
night that I'm not I'm probably going to
butcher but the essence is
um you spread the scripture everywhere
and sometimes you use words
right it's close something like that
John's saying yes so it's not perfect
somebody can look it up and put the
exact one in but the idea is like you're
spreading your message all the time
through who you are and how you act and
sometimes you're actually using your
words
sometimes the huge fan of Saint Francis
um sometimes what people need is a video
or they need a speech or they need pep
talk sometimes people just need a hug
sometimes people just need to see you
leading by example sometimes people
seeing you hold the door for somebody
inspires them to do something sometimes
seem seeing you with your team and you
being the last on the elevator instead
of the first and letting your team go
first maybe that inspires somebody right
so it's like constantly living the
message when you go through build to
serve when you figure out you're who
right mine is believe I'm not just
believe when I turn on the camera and go
on to YouTube it I am believe it is me
right and the best it's the best me that
I'm trying to bring everywhere so if I'm
just talking to Zan privately I'm still
trying to inject him with belief it's
not a strategy it's part of who I am and
same thing for all of you you show up
to try to gift this to yourself and
everybody around you whether your
mission is big and you want to change
the world or just the you know 25
closest people to you
um
yeah you you anyway I gotta memorize
that Saint Francis one because I love
that quote but it just really struck me
because so many people think you have to
be a different person when you're going
online or when you're making content
like the best is to actually be you
right this is not just a strategy to
share for social media this is a
strategy for life so yeah your goal is
to spread your your message to everybody
because imagine like belief mine is
belief whatever yours is it's something
powerful it's something positive I've
never seen somebody's one word be
hatred or
killing or something right like it's
always positive so if yours is freedom
there it is Raymond wow I said Freedom
this is that came up like if rain wins
his freedom
imagine allowing everybody to have a
little more freedom
right he's he wants to spread freedom to
everybody he wants to spread that to his
partner his kids his grandparents his
the people in his community and the
people watching his video it's not okay
I'm going to be Freedom only for my
content and then when I come home I'm
gonna
be a terrible husband or whatever right
I mean it's Freedom everywhere
Daniel saying interesting the book I
work on right now is the same principle
it can be started at almost any page
yeah and listen I had to fight for that
my publisher didn't like it she's
they're like there's no chapters in your
book people like to read chapters so it
needs to feel more substantial
um he also didn't like how I had a quote
on every page because we're quoting
Martin Luther King or JFK or or whoever
um so don't do that only do one per like
every 100 Pages or something
um
so no I don't like that so Raymond says
I love the quotes uh yeah I guess it's
just a different style
I I wrote the book how I would like to
read the book because I don't like to
read books much I like video learning
more so because I'm a slow reader and
takes me a while I like having the
bite-sized pieces so
um I'm glad you guys liked it and it
resonated uh your one word is written
the same way my first book and it's that
same same style and I had to fight with
my publisher on that one as well it's
just not typically how books are done
right and into
um Daniel's points like I didn't I
didn't convince them that it was right
I just said this is what I want to do if
you want to work with me this is this is
this is a non-negotiable for me it has
to be an easy to read book and if that
doesn't work for you awesome
uh I'll go somewhere else right not like
in a mean way like if it doesn't fit
your style and doesn't fit your catalog
hey awesome I don't want to spend
18 months convincing you that this is
the way that publishing is going right
like this is what I want to do if we
want to work together great if not you
know you move on
um
one last Quick story on that uh Zan and
I do our our nightly gaming stream
um with I play League of Legends and we
answer business questions it's apple
carmichael.live and when I first came up
with the idea I actually offered the
opportunity to my friend Mark because we
have a podcast together and we do a lot
of work together and it and I didn't
want I just felt right that he would be
the first guy that I offer it to and I
said there's no way you can do this but
I just want to let you know that I'm
doing this and I wanted to give you the
first opportunity
um he's got four kids and his wife and
his all-time and he's like hey I can
make it work if you move it half an hour
later
like I can't move it half an hour later
this is the time I have to do it so we
had to say no so then uh and I was
assuming that anyway so I then I
messaged saying I got this opportunity
I want to do this with you and he and
he's uh said okay I can do it every day
except whatever day because I got to go
pick up my wife or whatever
uh and then like no no whatever she she
can pick herself up I'm gonna do this
and I don't know whatever he worked it
out it happened you know maybe he's got
to cook extra for her or something but
you know Mark could couldn't make it
happen and Zayn did make it happen and
if Zan said no I was like Hey Zen no
worries man uh you got to be with your
wife great uh Pablo I'm certain this
show you interested right I mean just
I don't want to convince Zan to change
his whole life to make this work could
it be a great opportunity for him
absolutely will it you know is it worth
the effort maybe not same thing with my
friend Mark for a decade it would have
been amazing opportunity for him to say
yes but I'm not I don't want to be in
the business of convincing people right
it's just so much easier to go faster
when you're not trying to convince
people
this week's topic was Maria who picked
Niche picking one and staying with it
how to narrow when in it to include
another niche uh well since we have
Maria here why don't we uh Workshop this
a little bit what what's uh what's on
your mind where's this coming from
thank you Evan and thank you so much for
I'm just blown away with your generosity
with the challenge and
anyway um thank you so I've been you
know I've I've shifted my Niche a few
times over the years because I I address
women that struggle in their
relationship to food Weight and Body
Image but it's typically the tip of the
iceberg and usually the deeper blocks
the emotional block sometimes trauma
sometimes Stress Management sometimes
that's where you have to go to have
long-term healing and so
I'm you know I I Market to that
particular population but I work with
people that struggle with anxiety and
because that's usually the next layer
right people are medicating with food
it's a lot of times they're medicating
their anxiety or their and one of the
things I just watched your interview
with Melanie because I I am a emotional
Freedom techniques Master practitioner
and that's one of the techniques that I
actually use to one of them that help
people to have more peace in their with
their emotional body so my question is
do I just stick to this Niche or do I
broaden it like when is like when is the
time to do that or do I just keep doing
what I'm doing and because for instance
I'll work with someone and then she'll
send me her husband because her husband
has anxiety issues you know so
I don't know if that's clear no no I
mean thank you great and think everybody
kind of struggles with forms of this at
some point when they're figuring out
their content Their audience
um what you need to think about is who
so in in looking at your titles for the
movement makers challenge that we're
going through right now all your titles
came back to helping women right like
everything said women which is fine so
you know I love I'll believe in anybody
I like if somebody if you sent me
somebody who or I'm talking to somebody
who's an employee and never wants to be
an entrepreneur I'll still have the
conversation help them it's just not
really what I want to be doing you know
it's like it's not at the core of what I
love the most because that's I love
serving entrepreneurs more so it doesn't
mean that hey because you're a man I'm
not gonna talk to you you know but if
you love serving women then you focus on
that audience first
inside of that
you get the pick is it really mental
health stuff that you love about I love
caring about is it really the weight
loss Journey because that leads to the
mental health stuff you know like who do
you love helping the most like if you
had to pick we all love serving we all
love helping if we see somebody fall on
the street we're gonna go and and help
them up I hope readers built to serve
readers okay you see somebody follow the
street you go help them up but that's
not like what we want to you know be
spending our days doing it's just we see
somebody in need and we do what we can
to support
um you know right now uh the whole thing
in Ukraine like my main video editor her
she's Ukrainian and she left three uh no
she left like five years ago from
Ukraine to go to Montenegro and
um
because of war and potential war and all
that so she's safe but her family is in
the Ukraine and we've been spending the
past time kind of figuring out hey how
how can I help I mean I'm I'm in Canada
do they need money like is your family
safe can they fly out of the country can
they get somewhere where they need to go
you know I I don't speak the language or
have any connections but uh if if money
is a problem to get people what they
need like let me know
um and you know I'm helping with that
but it's not what I want my mission
isn't going into war-torn countries and
helping people escape but you know right
so we do what we can to serve the people
who are around us but like who do you
who would you spend or love spending the
most time with it's like just absolutely
feeds your soul who are they and what
are they struggling with in the
challenge of the movement makers
thing we're going through right now is
to try to get it more specific so that
when you're making the content it's not
just how to fix your anxiety
which is great but specific to like who
are the people who love helping the most
so in that context who do you who would
you love helping like the most the most
the most yeah so
my word is care
and my mission really is I feel
passionate about this is to to help
women to get beyond the struggles that
undermine them so that they can stand in
their life and and be their best self
and and serve in the way that they've
been called to serve because I feel like
the advancement of women and you know we
in this country we have we have more
freedom than many women on the planet
and yet we're emotionally oppressed by
Body Image issues and weight issues and
and all that chips away at us being our
best self so I feel passionate about
that and also my story is about that
I've come from multiple eating disorders
and I've worked in so I you know I'm on
the other side of that now and I feel
like my purpose is my passion I mean my
pain has been my passion
so yes that's that gives me greatest
pleasure when I have clients that are
you know getting beyond the dieting
stuff and and really looking you know
living a Freer life and they're and
they're finding their purpose beyond
that and not teaching their little
daughters to be over concerned about
diet and weight but that these girls can
come into the world with more empowered
about
who they are as a person not necessarily
how they look so I mean that's part of
it yeah I mean I love I love that you so
you have your Niche women which is
awesome now now that's like
half of the population so we've narrowed
it down a little bit but
getting a little more specific to then
the next step and the problem that
they're facing is helpful because if you
only said women who who aren't living
their best lives that's everybody that's
every woman that's every man too by the
way you know
separating their potential whatever so
it's very it's very broad which which is
the long-term Mission but then inside of
that who do you love helping the most
and whether it relates to food or not
that's the discussion I start to figure
out it's like hey we can we can start to
build this Niche and then expand from
there but inside of that like who do you
love love love helping the most like do
you love helping teenage girls get over
a crush that broke their heart on Prom
Night do you love helping
you know a woman who might have lost her
mom yesterday to cancer you know like
there's so many issues that we will face
and so it's great to Target women but
then what are they struggling with the
most that you love helping them through
and then that becomes
most of the content that you start with
so you can start building your tribe
around it yeah yeah yeah yeah
well it is women that are caught in in
struggling
with weight thinking they need a diet
that's going to fix them because it's
really an inside job right and so I get
great set like for instance I've been
working with a new client recently and
after a couple of weeks she's come to
the realization that it's really not
about her weight her unhappiness and her
and that's gives me great gratification
and satisfaction yes she wants to still
be healthy and treat her body with
respect but giving up the struggle and
learning to trust herself more is
that that's what gives me great
gratification that she's she's really
feeling more of um taking caring enough
about herself that she is willing to
have healthier boundaries with her
husband and rather than focusing on the
body image and all of that getting
beyond that is that is that clear yeah
yeah I think that's great like behind
every for all everybody here you want to
have an impact and we all have a message
to to serve other people
these strategies alone are not going to
be enough
like just telling somebody here's what
you do here's the foods to eat if I
could just tell somebody hey make these
videos go that's not enough because
there's there's emotional resistances to
everything
so you could tell somebody to eat this
food but there's a reason why they're
abusing the food in the first place all
of us have blocks that prevent us from
doing the next thing and so
understanding that really helps so
woman you're helping they're they're
stressed out or they have anxiety they
have body issues and some of them the
ones who you'll like helping the most
they solve they they feed their anxiety
and stress with food
others might do it through drugs others
might do nothing or relationships or
they cut themselves or they you know
like and
so that's where like well do you want to
help those women too if somebody's
saying like I've tried to kill myself
four times because I hate my body and
like maybe maybe you don't turn that
person away you know but it's not like
the core of what you want to deal with
because it's not the same path that you
went through right so if women great
awesome plus anxiety stress
self-confidence issues great that's
going to be everybody but how do they
fix though how are they getting their
fix off is through food
yeah and so you're still addressing the
underlying thing but also helping them
solve the connection to getting their
fix with food right so it's like food
but you're not just gonna teach diet
plans no you're going to teach them
techniques underneath
really of course and but it's not just
that those techniques only work through
food
it could also apply to people who are
cutting themselves or oh yes or for men
too who are doing these things it's just
not as much
of a connection to you because you
haven't gone through those things yeah
well I've gone through other addictive
behaviors and and and on because really
my understanding you know if you if you
just transfer one addiction to another
the expression is you're changing seats
on the Titanic I mean you're not
addressing the underlying you're still
going down right and what years ago when
I worked in an eating disorder unit by
the time people got there they had gone
through drug addiction and and gambling
addiction and so all of that stuff is
relevant and yes though as I work with
people for instance I'll work with
somebody who's a food issue and then all
of a sudden after a couple weeks they
feel safe enough with me to real to to
reveal that they drink a bottle of wine
every night and so as we uncover
the core reasons so it's you know on the
onset I I'm I tracked people and
sometimes people don't over well I guess
it has more to do with Rapport and
intimacy and Trust as they get to know
me and they feel safe with me then they
reveal more
about who they are and also knowing if
you've been through the thing that
they're going through because you can
make the connection between addictive
behaviors but other people may not right
so like have you ever lost your home
because of a gambling problem
well my father was a compulsive gambling
Gambler and we lost many homes
but so that's that speaks to like family
so my family members doing this but have
you ever done it
have I lost a home I haven't lost a home
but I've
lost a lot I don't have a gambling issue
great so but I have an issue with
supporting men because that came out of
that Dynamic that my mother I've had in
my history I don't do that today but in
my history I've supported men and given
them a lot of money
great I'm a little ashamed of even
saying that but it was because of the
Dynamics of the gambling you know so
that was a person you're in a safe space
and thank you for having the courage to
share that with us if you haven't told
other people before but these are things
that you can speak to right it's not
that if somebody has their own gambling
problem
um you won't help them but it's just not
it's not you you you didn't go and lose
your home but if somebody came and said
my father has again or my mother or
somebody my family has a gambling
addiction or I keep supporting people
for some reason why do I keep supporting
these men who have gambling problems
what is wrong with me like somebody that
person you would love helping so much
more than I have a gambling problem
because it's more through your
experience of what you've lived like if
somebody came to you and said I keep
supporting men who have gambling
problems what's wrong with me and then
you help them realize there's nothing
wrong with you
right and you teach them to actually
love yourself and just get out of these
negative relationships that's going to
make you feel amazing yes so it's and
hopefully I mean we're spending a lot of
time on this but hopefully everybody can
see that kind of similar Journey for
your own self the thing that you have
been through where you felt hopeless
worthless like when your dad did that
and you lost your home or you gave money
and just how terrible like it made you
feel terrible about yourself and if you
then subsidize through food like okay
well I'm just gonna go eat that pizza or
Doritos or whatever just to make me feel
good because I don't have any happiness
in my life anywhere right like this is
where people get really stuck so that's
your Niche you know the people who are
currently struggling with the thing that
you struggled through and it doesn't
mean we ignore everybody else we can't
help them and we're going to turn them
away but it's not who we're actively
trying to go out and serve because if
you just go out and say ladies have more
self-confidence it becomes too broad a
message
but then you end up we end up trying to
serve everybody and ends up serving very
few people
does that help yes it's very helpful I
have
I had the modalities that I do use is
tapping and I really love the
conversation you had with Melanie
because it's not all the only thing I
use and but a lot of my YouTube videos
have been focused on that because
there's a whole niche of people that are
but I use the tapping specific to that
weight body image and
so so like who I how right that from
Bill to serve that's the how the how the
how matters less about what the how is
and matters more that you believe in the
how like if if somebody sees you and say
I'm in the same situations Maria I've
been over eating to combat my stress
because of whatever happened in my life
and you're gonna say I'm exactly like
you here's how I got through it tapping
great show me how to do it like the how
does it matter
what matters is that it actually worked
for you yeah and that because I love you
and I connect to your story I'm gonna
now have more belief in the strategy
that you're gonna give me on how to get
out as well so if tapping helped you
then incorporate into your content yes
if it helped you for everything great
put it everywhere if it helped you only
for specific problems you should make it
for those specific problems but bringing
it into your content bring it into your
coaching whatever got you out of the
hole
is the thing then you teach other people
because that's your job is to get them
out of the hole that they're in as well
and we all have we all have different
house right and you don't have to use
the same have for every situation but
how did you get out of the situation you
were in and now we teach that yeah we're
thought leaders
I love it it just reminds me of somebody
booked a consult with me tomorrow and
when I when somebody books I ask them to
just put anything that they have to say
and she said she said I'm not sure about
tapping but I'm sure about you she's
been following me for a while yeah and
um it really just spoke to what you were
saying she felt comfortable enough to
have the consult with me to potentially
work with me but she wasn't sure about
tapping yeah like the how does it matter
this is why in movement makers for this
challenge that we're doing when when I'm
rejecting everybody putting in their
like their four steps to do things or
the three ways or the age like the
strategies do not matter
what matters is the connection to you I
don't given me eight strategies is not
the benefit
what's the specific the specific benefit
that I'm gonna get from working with you
and so that's the whole game if you get
them to to know you like you trust you
which comes from you telling your story
if I start talking about women's weight
issues
you're not a woman you don't know me you
don't know what I'm going through right
like it's gonna be the first like who
even if I have all the same strategies
they're not gonna listen to me because
I'm not a woman
right and and that's an obvious like
hopefully you can tell that I'm not a
woman
obvious thing but the thing is a lot of
these things that we
have struggled with are not obvious like
knowing that you struggled if I look at
you I don't think you struggle with food
if I look at you I don't think you had
men in your life who had gambling issues
that you supported so when you come out
and say Here's how you solve it it
doesn't come across like who is this
woman who's preaching to me
right you're not and this is hopefully
applicable to everybody like you're not
coming down from your high horse and
preaching people and telling people what
to do you're saying I'm just like you I
was I was in the same spot and I
struggled with this and here's how I
overcame but until you share that story
and I know that you've been through it
and you're at you're like me then then
I'm not going to listen to you so anyway
most things are not obvious right men
women obvious you know ethnic background
whatever scar on your face like super
obvious but most of the things we deal
with is not obvious and so we need to
share those things and have the courage
and you honestly did it right here it's
like I'm a little embarrassed to say
this it's great
and sharing that will only connect more
people to you like nobody if any people
only feel more love for you in saying
that you struggled with supporting men
who had gambling addictions not oh
I'm not going to talk to Maria now
because of that so thank you for having
the courage to uh to share up thank you
Evan thank you for all that you do thank
you if you want to get a copy of Bill to
serve and join us live for our next
training with me to ask your questions
you can go get the book right there next
to me right there I'll see you there
I'll see you to get the book it's a good
one much love